Шановні колеги Шановні українці
Кремль вбиває українців кожного дня
крем Руйнує нашу країну
причому головним чином руйнує цивільну
інфраструктуру для того щоб зробити
життя українців нестерпним Кремль
провокує світову продовольчу кризу
і одночасно Росія хоче щоб всі в Європі
повернулися до ситуації бізнесу з usual
і на жаль в деяких моментах станом на цю
хвилину це Їм вдається Тому що деякі
країни Європи дають їм візи Не дивлячись
на те що вони в санкційних списках їх
допускають до участі Я маю на увазі
представники України агресора Росії і
Білорусі
допускають до участі у всіх подіях
парламентської асамблеї ОБСЄ
І знаєте цинізм цієї ситуації додатковий
в тому що це все відбудеться якраз у
річницю
нападу повномасштабного 24 лютого
22-го року
саме тому ми вважаємо що така ситуація є
неприпустимою і я звертаюся до всіх
Одноголосно підтримати це звернення тому
що це не просто звернення Верховною ради
Це є чіткий план дій який ми пропонуємо
нашим міжнародним партнерам відносно
таких ситуацій де чітко прописано як ми
бачимо протидію
представникам країни-агресора під час
цих участі і ми сподіваємося не участі в
подіях міжнародних які відбудуться у
Відні а також це є чіткий сигнал всієї
Верховної Ради що хлопці і дівчата Я маю
на увазі ми звертаємося до Міжнародного
співтовариства не треба зараз давати
поступки тим хто продовжує вбивати Дякую
за увагу